justice league the snyder's cut is what
the 2017 should have been
this one is longer more thorough and 100
times better than the last one done by
joss whedon
as a monster channel we are bound by
oath to review and break down this movie
which had so many different races
species and super-powered individuals
this version has dark side and new gods
the old gods and many other races in the
mix
so here in this video we shall list out
and describe a little about these
different species
and races that appeared in the snyder's
cut we shall leave out humans as we all
know what we are
and what we can or cannot do so let us
get down with this sickness
number one yellen girl species the first
one on this list is an alien species
that appeared
thirty thousand years ago during the
first apocalyptian invasion of earth led
by darkseid himself
yellen gur was a green lantern that was
a member of a humanoid species from the
sector
2814 the same as earth this species
appears
as pink-skinned humanoids with pointy
ears and four
fingers per hand they are notably taller
than humans similar in stature to the
old gods
and the new gods but they share a
similar basic anatomy
yellen girl was a brave and dedicated
lantern assisting the armies of earth
to take on the young dark side and his
parademons
and greatly contributed to the latter's
defeat number two the martians
being one of the many surprises that the
snyder cut gave us the martian manhunter
made his debut appearance as martha ken
who consoled lois lane and encouraged
her to get back into the world
maybe knowing that she was the only one
who could calm down a resurrected
superman
martians are raised of intelligent green
skin humanoids who hail from the planet
mars
they possess the powers of
shape-shifting and telepathy but they
were all nearly wiped out by an unknown
event
at some point in the past the martian
anatomy is outwardly humanoid but
there are clear distinctions between
them and humans such as green skins
bright red eyes and elongated heads
inwardly they are even more different
with the martians having even more great
abilities than humans do
number three the new gods the new gods
are a space-faring race of nigh immortal
humanoid beings that
are native to the planet apocalypse they
include the likes of darkseid
their tyrant ruler then we have his
generals like stefan wolf
desaad granny goodness and the
apocalyptian priests which were all
sealed in good amounts in the snyder cut
the new gods are much more powerful
beings than humans
and many other species in the universe
however they are only matched or
surpassed by kryptonian
powered by solar energy or the old gods
they possess superhuman physical
abilities
and despite a large size however the new
gods have incredible superhuman speed
and agility that allows them to easily
overcome and overwhelm other smaller
and agile beings they can also react
quickly to high speed projectiles
the new gods are highly durable and they
possess technology that are
incomprehensible to the human mind
number four the old gods also known as
the greek gods or the olympians
they were an extra-dimensional race of
beings who were worshiped as
gods they occupied a realm known as
mount olympus which could be
something like mcu's asgard old gods
looked like humans due to humanity
having been created by zeus
in his image however they are much more
massive equal to the statue of a new god
like darkseid
they possess unparalleled divine
supernatural power
rivaling even kryptonians or new gods
they are able to summon immeasurably
powerful balls of energy
and use weapons that are capable of
destroying apocalyptian battleships
with ease as revealed by ares only a god
had the power to kill another god
and the old gods could also travel
between dimensions using their power
and also they are immortal number five
the parademons
then now we come to the heart of dark
side the parademons are a sentient
species of genetically modified and
enhanced super beings
created when altering other species with
the mother boxes there are
captured individuals from species like
humans or other alien species and are
cybernetically enhanced and mutated to
become
these hideous creatures darkseid
employed them during his attempted
planetary invasion of earth and later
again when fighting against the justice
league the parademons also have improved
physical abilities since they are
seen carrying people with ease they also
possess other skills like superhuman
agility and speed
they also have four wings that allow
them to fly at high speeds
some parademons possess a unique trait
of extending an extra pair of
insect-like
pincers from their abdomens used to
pierce their targets
these parademons are considerably larger
and seem to have a different head shape
compared to normal parademon troopers
number six atlanteans the atlanteans are
a group of four underwater species of
amphibious humanoids that were
originally terrestrial
but due to a catastrophe they now
inhabit the earth's oceans and are
native to the seven kingdoms of atlantis
they are a sister species of the human
race aside from the fishermen
the brine and the trench which shall not
be covered here since they didn't appear
here
two of the species are similar to humans
in appearance however they are
distinguished by their adaptation to
aquatic environments
they possess a highly efficient
respiratory system that allows them to
extract oxygen
from water allowing them to breathe
freely underwater only the highborn can
breathe air
atlanteans are shown to possess
superhuman strength and speed that allow
them to travel
immense distances underwater and their
body is durable to withstand
pressures of thousands of meters
underwater number seven the amazons
they are an all-female race of
superhuman warriors that occupy the land
of tamaskira
created by zeus they were mankind's
defense against the manipulations of
ares
however following the war of the gods
the amazons hid themselves
from the world although amazons are
generally similar to human women in
appearance
they are distinguished from them by
their remarkable beauty and
extreme physical strength the amazons
also possess an improved intellect that
allows them to quickly learn and adapt
additionally the amazons were gifted
with the ability to innately understand
all human languages including those
commonly dead
such as ancient greek latin sumerian or
turkish ottomans
and also they could learn alien
languages and number eight kryptonians
these are a critically endangered
species of aliens native to the planet
krypton
which exploded due to the instability of
the planet's radioactive core
but before that they were a galactic
powerhouse they are morphologically
anatomically especially identical to
humans in almost every way
except for the fact that they gain
incredible abilities when exposed to the
radiation of a yellow star
and becomes superpowered stronger than
any other species except for the old
gods
and the new gods the kryptonians possess
a level of technology rivaling that of
the new gods as well
which they went to war with in the past
and became enemies
they are one of the only species that
darkseid and the others were actually
cautious of
and so with that we come to the end of
this video do give us a thumbs up for
support and tell us if you like dc
content
here on this channel so subscribe to be
a part of the minecube family
and smash that bell button for regular
updates on new videos on monsters
kaiju and more right here on mind cue
take care fam